on va tout de suite passer à la seconde
partie de cette émission c'est l'autre
impasse du conflit entre israélien et
palestinien on va consacrer la 2uxè
partie de l'émission je disait la
situation en sixjordanie ce territoire
rogné mité et puis surtout occupé depuis
plus d'un demi-siècle la situation était
déjà tendu avant les attaques
terroristes du Hamas le 7 octobre mais
depuis elle devient quasiment explosive
retour sur des années de tension avec
Samia
dechir une cinquantaine de kilomètres
sépare les deux territoires palestiniens
à l'est la bande de Gaza pilonnée sans
relâche par l'armée israélienne depuis
l'attaque terroriste du Hamas à l'ouest
la 6 Jordanie qui en pai elle aussi les
conséquences depuis le 7 octobre 180
Palestiniens y ont été tués il y a
d'abord les raides de l'armée
israélienne le 9 novembre dernier 14
personnes sont mortes dans une incursion
à génine considéré comme un bastion de
la résistance à occupation israélienne
les images qui arrivent de la bande de
Gaza sont d'une
telle force émotionnelle que en sis
Jordanie on a des groupes qui auparavant
étaient des groupes disons plutôt
sporadiques qui essaient organiser entre
eux qui maintenant essaient en tout cas
de d'appeler à la manifestation à la
révolte à l'émeut et donc on a l'armée
israélienne qui va démultiplier les
incursions les opération dans des villes
palestiniennes afin si vous voulez de de
tuer dans l'œuf les groupes armés et
puis il y a les attaques des israélien
sur les villages
palestiniens depuis l'attaque du Hamas
sur Israël les expéditions punitives des
colons serai passé de 3 à 7 par jour
selon
l'ONU depuis le 7 octobre la situation a
complètement changé nous n'avons pas pu
nous rendre sur nos terr car les colons
et l'armée israélienne nous tirent
dessus des opérations souvent menées
conjointement avec l'armée israélienne
car les colons ont désormais intégré les
rangs des militaires en tant que
réserviste mobilisé après l'attaque du 7
octobre on avait par le passé une espèce
si vous voulez de lien disons entre
citoyens entre colons et soldat
israéliens là maintenant on a des colons
qui sont parmi même l'armée israélienne
donc ça veut dire que lorsque les colons
vont attaquer ou vont commettre des
exactions contre des paysans ou des
villages palestiniens et bien on a des
soldats qui sont à leur côté pour les
aider d'après l'ONU près de la moitié
des violences commises par des colons en
6is Jordanie sont sous tenu voire
accompagné par l'armée
israélienne la situation en S Jordanie
on en parle ce soir avec mes invités
bonsoir Damien simonau vous êtes maître
de conférence en scienceces politique à
linalco à vos côté Amélie zacour bonsoir
bonsoir vous êtes journaliste au service
international du grand quotidien
libanais francophone l'Orient le jour et
puis j'accueille également offer
Bronstein président du Forum
international pour la paix et la
réconciliation au Moyen-Orient et chargé
d'une mission par Emmanuel Macron pour
le rapprochement Israël aux palestinen
pour le rapprochement
israelllo-pestinien et puis bien sûr Tam
qui continue de m'accompagner tout au
long de cette émission fidèle au poste
voilà fidèle au poste alors on en parle
évidemment beaucoup moins que que Gaza
et pourtant la situation en sjordanie
qui est l'autre territoire palestinien
est dramatique hein depuis les massacres
du 7 octobre dernier on parle de plus de
160 Palestiniens qui auraient trouvé la
mort lors de raid mené par l'armée
israélienne et parfois par des colons
plus de 2000 blessés près de 850
expulsés de leur terre tout ça depuis le
7 octobre est-ce que c'est une gu qui se
passe en en S Jordanie Damien Simono
c'est un conflit larvé ENF voilà bien
évidemment depuis un mois il y a eu une
accentuation des tensions une
accentuation des violences notamment qui
émane des colons les plus extrêmes on
pourra redéfinir revenir un peu sur qui
sont les colons qu'est-ce qu'on a
derrière ce terme et puis bien
évidemment des actes d'attaque également
de la part des Palestiniens avec des
incursions également israéliennes dans
plusieurs villes notamment à Jenine je
crois il y a 2 jours donc en fait on est
dans quelque chose qui se continue hein
avant il y a eu l'année 2022 par exemple
a été extrêmement meurtrière également
pour les Palestiniens depuis 2005 donc
on a en fait une la routine quelque part
de l'occupation c'est c'est un peu
bizarre de dire ça mais en tout cas ces
tensions sont persistantes et c'est
quelque chose qui s'est accéléré ou qui
a redoublé de violence depuis les
attaques du 7 octobre oui bien sûr déjà
depuis le début de l'année donc pour
compléter ce que Damien disait il y a
322 palestiniens qui ont été tués en
6jordanie dont 123 depu depuis le 7
octobre donc on voit bien que il y a eu
une recrudescence des violences commise
notamment par les colons et aussi par
l'armée souvent avec lacord acide de
l'armée et et il y a d'autres problèmes
aussi comme une recrudesence d'activité
du Hamas au ferbonine ce sont des des
opérations armées ce sont des bavures ce
sont des règlements de compte c'est un
peu tout ça Jordan oui c'est un peu tout
ça c'est inquiétant parce que vous savez
des théories israéliens avance c'est que
si le 7 octobre l'attaque du khamas
était aussi efficace entre entre
guillemets c'est parce qu'une partie de
l'armée s'était déplacée de la bande de
Gaza donc aujourd'hui pour protéger
l'économie aujourd'hui voilà les colons
sont supposés protégés donc je me
demande si l'armée se retire là ça va
être beaucoup mais les colons profitent
de la situation pour faire des
provocations et je crois qu'on joue avec
le feu on joue avec le feu c'est très
très dangereux parce que si la S
Jordanie prend feu c'est ça peut
contaminer la Jordanie et là c'est un
autre c'est un autre BG c'est un autre
les règles du jeu seront totalement
différentes qui embrasera toute la
région la région la région il faut être
très vigilant il faut que ce qu'on
appelle la communauté internationale en
tout cas les amis d'Israël lui fasse
comprendre comme il faut comprendre au
libanais aujourd'hui que il faut faut
faut vraiment être très très très
vigilant et empêcher que la S Jordanie
prenne prenne feu heureusement que
l'Autorité palestinienne avec le très
peu de moyens qu'elle a elle arrive plus
ou moins à gérer la sécurité mais mais
mais ça ça aur ça a des ses limites
alors pour que tout le monde comprenne
bien de quoi on parle on va essayer
d'expliquer au téléspectateur ce que
c'est classie Jordanie et et son
histoire et on va le faire avec Steve
Jourdain que j'invite à à rentrer sur ce
plateau rebonsoir Steve bonsoir alors la
la sis Jordanie c'est quoi c'est d'un
territoire qui est situé à l'est de la
Jordanie et à l'ouest d'Israël on va
voir plein de cartes Mathieu avant 48 et
la création de l'État d'Israël la
sjordanie n'existe pas en tant que il y
a plusieurs implantations juives
notamment à Hébron dans la région mais
la guerre israëlo-arabe de 48 va
complètement rebattre les cartes la
Transjordanie Emira qui correspond très
vulgairement à l'actuelle Jordanie
conquierre la zone après du coup cette
guerre israëlo arabe de 48 ça va
désormais s'appeler la 6 Jordanie voilà
on voit la 6 Jordanie pourquoi 6
Jordanie bah c'est en DESS ça de la
Jordanie la Jordanie que vous voyez donc
à droite la Jordanie qui donc s'étend à
cette période entre 48 et 67 sur les
deux rives du fleuve Jourdain il faut
attendre 67 et la guerre des 6 jours
pour qu'Israël s'empare de ce territoire
au passage on voit pas mais l'État
hébreux conquièent Jérusalem est là où
se trouve les lieu saint juifs chrétiens
et musulmans et c'est à ce moment-là que
débute la colonisation israélienne en C
Jordanie oui la colonisation considérée
comme illégale par la communauté
internationale mais au départ vu comme
nécessaire notamment par la gauche
israélienne au pouvoir qui estime euh
alors qu'il s'agit d'un impératif de
sécurité les colonies sont implantées au
départ dans des endroits stratégiques
pour empêcher d'éventuels attaque euh de
la part en provenance de pays arabes
voisins 56 ans plus tard les choses ont
changé la droite est arrivé au pouvoir
en Israël les motifs nationalistes les
motifs religieux ont remplacé les
motivations sécuritaires on va voir la
la carte he des colonies en s-jordanie
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est qu'on compte
aujourd'hui 146 colonies israéliennes on
compte plus de 4 460000 juifs israéliens
qui vivent dans ces implantations 20000
autres sont présents dans les
avant-postes ce sont des implitations
qui sont illégal non seulement au regard
du droit international mais aussi au
regard du droit israélien alors
justement en matière juridique une
répartition des compétences a été engagé
au moment des accords d'Oslo entre
Israël et l'Autorité palestinienne oui
accord d'Oslo de 93 qui consacre la
reconnaissance mutuelle entre Israël et
l'OLP représentante du peuple
palestinien l'Organisation de Libération
de la Palestine on voit cette fameuse
poignée de main entre Isra rbine et
Yasser Arafat on parle alors de
processus de paix qui doit aboutir à
terme la création d'un État palestinien
souverain première étape du processus la
création de l'Autorité palestinienne un
organe autonome chargé de gérer au nom
des Palestiniens plusieurs zones en
sisjordanie et à Gaza les territoires
sont dévisés ad administrativement en
fonction des acteurs responsables de
leur gestion on va voir les territoires
de la zone A sont sous contrôle exclusif
civil et sécuritaire des Palestiniens
cela inclut notamment la bande de Gaza
VO exactement dans la zone B les
Palestiniens gèrent l'administration
civile Israël est responsable de la
sécurité ce qui implique le maintien de
la présence de l'armée sur ces
territoire et puis la zone C quant à
elle sous administration sous contrôle
exclusif d'Israël c'est ici que se
trouve les colonies israéliennes on
parle de 60 % de la surface de la
totalité de la 6 Jordanie mais ce sont
des zones qui sont peu densément
peuplées toutes ces zones auraient dû
disp paraître à la faveur d'un accord
final de paix entre Israël et les
Palestiniens accord final qui n'a pas
encore eu lieu accord final qu'on attend
toujours merci Steve alors on voit bien
avec cette carte en poau de léopard pour
reprendre une expression célèbre c'est
pas un ensemble homogène la ST Jordani
Dami Simono et même au sein des
territoires administrés par par les
Palestiniens absolument pas et en fait
je crois que ça pose la question de
qu'est-ce que c'est que l'occupation au
quotidien l'occupation au quotidien pour
les Israéliens et les Palestiniens qui
vivent dans cette zone je vous rappelle
que c'est des millions d'habitants qui
habitent sur une surface qui est plus
petite que la Corse il faut bien se
représenter ça qui est fait de zones
montagneuses de Jérusalem S mais aussi
de la vallée du Jourdain et du désert
également de judé au sud de la S
Jordanie avec jérusalems ça fait plus de
700000 colons exactementon app col on a
vu un chire de 400000 colons mais c'est
hors la M qui rappelons-le au regard du
droit international Israël en tant que
puissance occupante depuis 1967 ça a été
rappelé dans une résolution du Conseil
de sécurité de l'ONU en décembre 2016
n'a pas le droit de transférer sa
population civile dans cet espace donc
qui doit être notamment déterminé par
éventuellement des négociations avec les
Palestiniens donc ce que je disais c'est
que l'occupation elle est vécu très
différent différemment pour les
populations palestinennes ou pour les
populations israéliennes les colons en
Israël c'est qui ce sont donc des
centaines de milliers de personnes qui
parfois vivent dans des villes dans des
grandes villes qui ont l'impression
d'être dans la banlueue de Jérusalem ou
la banlue de telavive qui vivent là
parce que les loyers sont moins chers
parce qu'ils ont des facilitations
fiscales et ensuite vous avez des colons
dans des zones rurales dans les fameuses
avantpostes qui ne sont même pas
reconnus par Israël là vous avez des
colons beaucoup plus extrémistes et pour
les Palestiniens si on se concentre pour
les pales pour les Palestiniens les
Palestiniens en effet vivent dans ces
trois zones majoritairement en zone A
puisqu'ils sont sous l'autorité
palestinienne même si l'armée
israélienne peut continuer à mener des
des incursions ça a été le cas je le
disais à Janine et à nplous il y a
encore quelques mois et il travaille
d'ailleurs avec les services de sécurité
de l'Autorité palestinienne et dans les
zones B et C c'est là où l'affrontement
se fait pour le contrôle de la terre
avec ces fameux colons et le AOR l'armée
israélienne pardon et là ce qui s'est
passé maintenant depuis un mois c'est
qu'il y a on estime à peu près 800
personnes d'après l'ONG Betselem qui est
une ONG de documentation de des
violations des droits de l'homme dans
cette zone cette ONG dit que 800
personnes ont été déplacé depuis le 7
octobre suite à des attaques de Colon
avec le soutien de l'armée notamment
dans les zones rurales sont souvent des
populations bédouines isolé pour
justement contrôler encore plus
certaines zones qu'ils estiment
stratégiques alors on le disait pas
moins de 11 résolutions des Nations
Unies pour condamner l'occupation de la
sjordanie et les atteintes aux civils
dans la dernière vous y faisiez allusion
elle date de 2016 le Conseil de sécurité
exigeait d'Israël qu'il arrête
immédiatement et complètement toutes ses
activités de peuplement dans le
territoire palestinien occupé y compris
Jérusalem Est et respecte pleinement
toutes les obligations juridiques qui
incombent à cet égard sans aucun effet
Auer Bronstein régulièrement il y a des
réunions du Conseil de sécurité il y en
a encore une le 27 septembre dernier
soit quelques jours avant les massacres
du 7 octobre la communauté
internationale elle parle et elle se
soucie peu évidemment de de
l'application de ces résolutions sur le
terrain pour les Israéliens oui tant
qu'il y aura pas une
détermination de la part de des
Américains de la part des locomotives
européennes surtout celles qui sont
membres du du Conseil de sécurité je
pense en particulier à la France et tant
qu'il aura pas des action fermes Israël
n'écoutera pas y a un laisser faire de
la communauté internationale sur ce qui
se passe en
faire aussi par compréhension de la
situation politique dans lesquell les
gouvernement israéliens se trouvent
parce que l'excuse le prétexte ou les
raisons de des gouvernements israéliens
c'est de dire nous avons une coalition
problématique si on va dans votre
direction on va perdre le pouvoir si on
perd le pouvoir on pourra pas aller de
l'avant donc c'est un cercle vicieux
qu'Israël vit depuis très très longtemps
et c'est des excuses qui qui lui
permettent de continuer et par une bande
de voyou il faut il faut appeler chat
chat qui sont les voyou dit je vais le
dire il faut appeler un chat chat et je
crois qu'une partie des colons sont des
organisations pour moi c'est des
organisations terroristes c'est un
concert dans le cœur de de la société
israélienne il mène la société
israëlienne vous savez j'ai travaillé
avec itraak Rabin il a été assassiné
presque jour pour jour maintenant le le
le le 4 novembre
1995 le ce ce gouvernement israélien là
qui a dans son gouvernement des gens qui
ont appelé à l'assassinat de Rabine des
gens et qui appartenaient au même
mouvement que oui des gens des gens qui
appellent à la libération de de de son
assassin pour moi etra Rabine a été
assassiné deux fois c'est quelque chose
que je ne pouvais pas concevoir que des
ces gens-là soient à l'intérieur et je
vais vous dire pire je comprends la
frustration des Palestiniens quand vous
avez un ministre israélien qui dit on va
on va raser Kwara qui est une une
colonie pas loin de de de
Jérusalem quel est le message c'est un
message de de terreur qu'il veut qu'il
veut communiquer donc il va falloir et
j'espère que le prochain gouvernement
israélien va se barrasser de ces gens-là
parce qu'ils mettent Israël en danger
ils mettent on parle vous parlez
d'antisémitisme tout à l'heure ils
mettent les Juifs en danger parce que un
des arguments c'est de dire ah vous avez
un ministre qui a dit qu'il fallait
jeter une bombe atomique aussi de du
même parti d'extrême droite sur Gaza ah
vous avez un ministre qui appelle à
libérer des des des des assassins d'une
famille palestinien qui a été brûlé vif
donc Israël doit se débarrasser de ces
gens-là il pent préjudice à Israël il
porte préjudice au palestin et porte
préjudice aux Juifs la communauté juive
mondiale Amise à cour qu'est-ce qui
reste à l'Autorité palestinienne comme
pouvoir aujourd'hui en S Jordanie pas
grand-chose l'Autorité palestinienne est
totalement discréditée euh pour
plusieurs raisons d'abord ça fait très
longtemps que marmoudabbas est au
pouvoir il a 88 ans il est vieillissant
il est accusé de corruption rappelle
qu'il a pas eu d'élection en C Jordanie
2016 ouais 2016 HM
et en plus de ça il est aussi accusé de
de collaborer avec Israël puisqu'il y a
une coordination sécuritaire comme
Damien Simono l'a l'a
précisé donc voilà toutes ces raisons
font qu'il est énormément discrédité et
même si pour l'instant le le processus
politique palestinien semble très
lointain parce qu'on est encore dans la
guerre on ne sait pas du tout quelle
forme il va prendre à l'issue de de ce
conflit et est-ce qu'il pourrait y avoir
un interlocuteur du coup plausible qui
serait pas marmou bas du côté
palestinien alors pour l'instant il y en
a pas beaucoup qui ont émergé de manière
sérieuse il y a des noms qui commencent
à circuler il y a Marwan bargouti qui
est une ancienne figure du fata qui est
est emprisonné exactement en israë plus
faut
libérer on va on va y venir la p mais
faisons d'abord un un focus sur sur à
quoi à quoi ressemble au fond la vie
quotidienne en
sjordanie je vous propose d'écouter le
témoignage d'un étudiant moy d'fané il
est étudiant en droit à l'université al
à abouis il a 22 ans
écoutez bien sûr nous faisons face à de
nombreux défis et ce mur derrière nous
en est l'exemple plus parfait nous ne
pouvons plus visiter Jérusalem et nous
rendre à Alaka même si nous voulons
traverser pour travailler nous ne
pouvons pas 70 % des hommes à abouis
sont été signalés sans raison la vie est
devenue bien plus difficile
dam déjà la vie en Jordanie c'est la vie
derrière des murs derrière des barrières
hautes ça que vous raconter aussi aux
gens qui nous regardent alors
l'occupation du point de vue des
Palestiniens c'est quoi c'est une énorme
bureaucratie qui lorsqu'ils veulent se
déplacer lorsqu'ils veulent aller
travailler en Israël lorsqu'ils veulent
même voyager parfois à l'étranger les
Palestiniens doivent passer par ce qu'on
appelle le kogat c'est-à-dire là oou
l'administration civile qui est un
organe qui est maintenant sous la coupe
de betsales motrc qui est sous la coupe
d'un d'un ministre d'extrême
droiteitaire c'est un organe militaire
et les Palestiniens en fait doivent
demander des permis pour cela pour se
déplacer donc d'abord l'occupation c'est
une bureaucratie dans lequel tous les
Palestiniens de syjordanie vivent
ensuite l'occupation c'est un dispositif
physique architectural et NOTAM VO
derrière voilà notamment le mur moi se
trouve que j'ai travaillé sur ces
politiques là et en gros depuis le début
des années 2000 Israël a mis en place à
accentuer une politique de séparation
des populations notamment alors sous
prétexte de sécurité puisque à l'épque
il y avait des attentats suicides de la
part de groupes palestiniens dans les
zones d'habitation israélienne mais le
détermination de ce mur a permis en fait
à Ariel Charon et notamment l'architecte
qui est un colon aussi Dani Atar à
l'époque de de de tracer ce mur et de
restreindre encore plus l'accès aux
terres agricoes donc en effet la vie
d'un Palestinien dans ces différentes
enclaves que vous avez montré elle est
faite de Checkpoint de choses
extrêmement fluctuantes il ne sait pas
combien de temps vont il va prendre par
exemple pour aller d'une ville à une
autre et là il se trouve que au sud de
naplous ou de Jenine et bien là les
Israéliens ont remis des formes de
Checkpoint ces derniers mois pour
contrôler à nouveau et cetera donc c'est
ça la vie en effet pour un Palestinien
et depuis le 7 octobre suspension de
permis de travail en plus accordé les
Palestiniens qui travailler en Israël du
coup toute la vie économique est au
ralenti c'est une catastrophe c'est une
catastrophe on a appelé excusez-moi on a
appelé le à l'intérieur du gouvernement
il y a a un grand débat et ils disent il
faut leur donner de l'argent parce que
il ne travaillent pas parce que nous on
a fermé la la frontière et si on leur
donne pas de l'argent c'est une
catastrophe économique nou parce que
certains travaillent en Israël certains
travaillent même
pouron0000 qui on des permis de travail
plus ou moins régulier à part ce qui on
avait à gazam c'est une autre histoire à
part ça il y a une 50 60000 qui
travaillent d'une façon illégale et je
ne compte pas ceux qui travaillent les
Palestiniens de Jérusalem Est qui sont
considérés comme citoyens Israëliens
donc l'économie palestinienne dépend
totalement des des travailleurs
palestiniens qui travaillent en Israël
ne travaillons pas depuis un un mois ça
risque d'être une explosion économique
aussi et je voudrais signaler quelque
chose il faut comprendre au niveau de la
de la législation comment ça marche les
israéliens sont régis par la loi
israélienne alors que les Palestiniens
sont régis par une loi militaire euh
c'est pas le même c'est c'est pas la
même la même chose et on voit comment
les lois militaires israéliennes sont
un/ers des 1/ers des hommes Palestiniens
sont passer par les prisons israéliennes
c'est énorme donc je comprends les
frustrations mais d'un autre côté ce qui
me désole c'est que parfois aussi de du
côté de mes amis Palestiniens il ne
comprennent pas les craintes de d'Israël
israël vit dans une paranoïa que que le
monde Arab veut la détruire pour de
bonnes et de mauvaises raisons alors on
va s'intéresser un peu aux colonies au
départ les premières colonies on l'a
évoqué avec Steve dans les années 70
était jugée illégale elle été soutenue
par le pouvoir mais était illégale au
regard du droit israélien et puis il
semble que c'est devenu une arme
politique notamment depuis l'arrivée de
de Benjamin netaniahou au pouvoir avec
un nombre d'écolonie a explosé c'est ce
qu'on appelle la stratégie du du fait
accompli alors depuis que anou est
revenu au pouvoir vous voulez dire il y
a un an non mais même depuis sa première
sa première arrivée quand on regarde le
nombre de colonies il explose il explose
depuis eu certes ça fait longtemps qu'il
est au pouvoir netaniaahou mais de toute
façon le nombre de colons a cadruplé en
30 ans en tout cas clairement il y a y a
il y a une politique procolonisation
surtout avec le le nouveau gouvernement
qui est composé de figures d'extrême
droite et du sionisme religieux mais je
voudrais compléter ce qui a été dit par
par mes deux collègues autour de cette
table et qui s'inscrit dans cette
question aussi c'est qu'en fait sur les
restrictions de mouvement euh en 6h d'
aujourd'hui on a des localités qui sont
totalement cadrillées par l'armée enfin
moi il y avait des gens qui me parlaient
à Huara qui est une localité qui a été
la cible d'une opération punitive par
des colons israéliens en février après
que deux colons ont été tués par des
Palestiniens et en fait il se trouve que
cette localité est situé sur une route
qui coupe laassordan du nord au sud et
les magasins sont complètement fermés
dans cette ville tout est quadrillé il y
a des couvrefeu il y a des des gens de
là-bas qui me disaient on a l'impression
d'être à la frontière avec un autre pays
et les répercussions économiques vont
être terribles c'est quelque chose qu'il
faudra mesurer à terme là j'ai vu aussi
que l'ONU a dit qu'il allait avoir plus
de 200000 emplois qui allaient être
supprimé en 6 Jordanie donc c'est
vraiment des choses qu'il faut garder en
tête et à terme alors vous parliez de
ces exactions des colons soutenu par
l'armée je vous propose d'écouter le
témoignage du Rabin haric Acherman de
l'on pour les droits de l'homme
remarquable voilà il monte il monte la
garde dans une olivée de 6 Jordanie
occupé il protège les agriculteur
palestinien de la vague de violence qui
les vise depuis la guerre entre Israël
et le Hamas à Gaza
regardez sur le terrain nous continuons
d'assister à la violence endémique des
colons qui n'est pas contrôlé les forces
de sécurité ne sont pas disposés à lever
le petit Doig pour protéger les
Palestiniens malheureusement nos forces
de sécurité soutiennent presque
totalement directement ou indirectement
les colons qui nettoie toute cette zone
de la présence
palestiniennein l'armée elle a des
ordres elle suit des consignes donc
quand on dit que l'armée protège
directement indirectement les colons
c'est une volonté du pouvoir politique
oui et non l'armée a des ordres l'armée
a des consignes ça dépend de qui est le
qui est au pouvoir et ça dépend aussi de
d'initiative personnell de certains
soldats il y a des soldats qui font un
travail humain remarquable parce que
pour un soldat israélien être là-bas
c'est c'est c'est difficile c'est
pénible il est confronté à une
population il fait du travail le travail
d'un policier il fait pas le travail
d'un soldat parce qu'il est confronté à
une population civile il
maintien de l'ordre et parfois dans des
situations humaines très pénibles une
mère qui doit se faire soigner son fils
dans un hôpital palestinien qui est
bloqu israélien et qui est bloqué dans
un checkpoint pendant 3 4 5 he alors
qu'il fait 45 degrés à l'ombre et et le
soldat voudrait l'aider et il ne peut
pas il y en a qui le font il y en a qui
ont le courage de faire d'ailleurs il y
a une organisation israélienne d'ex
soldats israéliens qui font un travail
remarquable de à coup et de dire moi je
sais ce qui s'est passé mais vous voulez
direce quand l'armée laisse les colons
faire oui ça dépend au fond des tempér
des soldats ont là oui ça dépend aussi
des opinions politiques des des soldats
parce que le soldat c'est en fin de
compte quelqu'un comme vous et moi qui a
des des des des des des opinions
politiques et n'oubliez pas que les
colons sont armés les les Palestiniens
ne le sont pas mais à côté de ça c'est
pour ça que je garde quand même un
certain optimisme contrairement à Gaza
qui est complètement fermé depuis 20 ans
aux Israéliens bien que la loi
israélienne aujourd'hui interdit aux
Israéliens de rentrer dans les
territoires palestiniens ce qui est
dramatique et interdit sauf les
palestiniens qui ont un permis de
travail leur interdit de rentrer en
Israël donc le contact entre les deux
populations est devenu très limité et ça
c'est tragique parce qu'il une jeune
génération d'Israéliens de Palestiniens
qui ne se connaissent pas qui ne se
parlent pas qui ne font pas de choses
ensemble alors qu'il le devrai mais il y
a des colons il y a des il y a des des
israélien courageux comme comme ce Rabin
et l'association des rabins pour le
droit de l'homme comme médecin pour les
droits de l'homme en Israël il y en a
plein d'autres font un travail
remarquable de de garder le contact AC
palestinien de de travailler avec
eux c'est c'est c'est c'est tellement
pénible parce qu'on était tellement
proche de la paix vous vous mentionnez
les accords d'Oslo vraiment les
Israéliens les Palestiniens passé leur
journée les uns chez les autres et là on
est revenu voilà moi je suis afféré et
j'ai très peur de ce qui va se passer on
va y revenir évidemment à la fin de
l'émission juste puisqu'on on va clore
ce ce chapitre sur les colonies raconte
ce que c'est que qu'une colonie comment
ça se crée une colonie ça se crée à coup
de pelleteuse à coup d'encerclement comm
ça ça se passeou oui alors il y a
plusieurs choses mais vous avez des
colonies qui sont vraiment des des
banlieux très très structuré très
grandes alors il y a toute une
architecture de du contrôle du
territoire dans des zones qui sont
montagneuses la colonies sont souvent
pour celles qui sont validées par l'État
se situent dans les hauteurs parce que
les villes palestiniennes sont plutôt en
bas historiquement donc il y a en fait
c'est moyen à jeux c'est pour surveiller
l'ennemi quand oui voilà c'estàdire qu'
il y a une forme de de surveillance
panoptique il y a des architectes
commeal veisman qui ont très bien étudié
cela donc tout cela est pensé et c'est
notamment pour ça que dans les années 70
notamment même si le gouvernement était
à gauche certains ont appuyé ces
implantations là notamment parce que
cela permettait de de de de préserver la
sécurité soi-disant de de de des
pleaines côtières où habite la majorité
de la population israéenne précision la
première colonie c'est la gauche
israélienne qui l'a créé c'est Shimon
perz c'est Shimon Perrez pris Nobel de
la paix c'est le premier qui pour des
raison sécuritaire à l'époque mais
faudrait lui demander mais national et
j'aimerais juste rajouter quelque chose
sur sur la colonisation je crois qu'il y
a un élément qu'on n pas évoqué ici il
faut bien se rendre compte que les
colons entre guillemets c'est à la fois
un mouvement un réseau qui est très
influent sur les réseaux sociaux
actuellement vous avez des des colons
aujourd'hui qui se félicite du retour de
l'armée israélienne à Gaza et qui poste
des photos en hébreux là-dessus parce
qu'ils ont derrière cette idée nous
allons pouvoir recoloniser nous
réinstaller à Gaza comme après 2005 et
ensuite les colons sont maintenant
présents à l'intérieur de l'appareil
d'État israélien c'est de plus en plus
difficile de dissocier et notamment
depuis le gouvernement qui est
maintenant en place depuis 1 an dans
l'armée il y a un lobby très important
qui s'appelle le Yesa Council enfin le
Conseil Yesa qui représente les
implantations qui fait du lobbying à la
cissette ou ailleurs et maintenant ils
sont au gouvernement alors puisquon
parle je peux vous dire qu'il les
soutient parce qu'on croit que c'est la
droite israélienne c'est pas la droite
israélienne c'est c'est évangéliste
américain le grand soutien au niveau
financier au niveau politique des
colonies et des colons c'est la
l'extrême droite évangéliste américain
60 millions de personnes avec l'aspect
mécianique justement et et puisque vous
en parlez je vous propose de regarder un
Portra
qui été est un extrait en fait d'un
documentaire qui s'appelle le descendant
qui est un film de Stéphane Girard
produit par C et compagnie
[Musique]
regardez
בר
שלכומ
בכ
vou
VI donc si Abraham a acheté le terrain
il y il y a plus rien à dire vous savez
moi je suis vraiment
révolté aussi bien le khamas que
l'extrême droite israélienne veulent que
ce conflit devienne un conflit religieux
et quand on dit que Dieu a dit c'est
difficile de alors que c'est un conflit
politique d'ailleurs l'opération du
khamas ils l'ont appelé opération pour
sauver àaka pour sauver la la la mosqué
à Jérusalem ils veulent rendre ce
conflit religieux pour le le rendre
impossible à régler mais je vais vous
dire autre chose moi je suis révolté par
les noms qu'on don il faut il faut dire
les noms comme il faut ça veut dire quoi
une terre sainte ça veut dire quoi des
lieux saints j'arrive pas à comprendre
pourquoi il y a une seule chose qui est
simple c'est c'est la vie c'est la vie
humaine et aujourd'hui il y a des gens
que pour une pierre saine sont sont prêt
à à se sacrifier que pour un lieu sain
sont prêt à se sacrifier et et ça je je
n'arrive pas à le concevoir moi j'ai
beaucoup plus de respect pour les
maternités que pour les cimetières et
alors qu'il y a des beaucoup trop qui
ont du respect pour des cimetières AB
Abraham avec tout le respect que je lui
dois c'était il y a combien de milliers
d'années alors avant d'évoquer ensemble
les les les avenir possible de la S
Jordanie s'il y en a et on comprend que
la situation est extrêmement compliquée
on va faire un petit détour par Paris
avec vous Tam pour tenter des voir plus
clair sur les avenirs possibles de la
diplomatie française au Proche Orient et
surtout est-ce qu'on essaie d' voir plus
clair dans les déclarations du président
de la République parce qu'Emmanuel
Macron s'est exprimé sur la BBC c'était
vendredi et il a fait une prise de
parole qui a fait beaucoup réagir is et
on va l'écouter
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui des civils sont
bombardés de facto des bébés des femmes
des personnes âgées sont bombardées et
tuées il n'y a aucune légitimité à cela
nous exhortons Israël à
arrêter donc voilà ce que déclare
Emmanuel Macron après avoir affiché dans
un premier temps un soutien total à
Israël c'est une nouvelle version du en
même temps macronist d'abord je dirais
qu'il n'est pas strict dans le en même
temps puisqu'il a dit tout son soutien à
Israël après l'attaque terroriste du 7
octobre le 12 octobre exactement il a
ensuite bien a proposé sa coalition
internationale contre le Hamas une
initiative au succès plus que mitigé
c'était le 24 octobre et il a plaidé
donc pourra in cesser le feu le 9
novembre soit jeudi dernier lors de la
conférence humanitaire organisée à Paris
juste avant son entretien avec la BBC
donc ce n'est pas par définition du en
même temps puisque ces prises de paroles
se sont succédés sur un mois un mois
c'est aussi le le temps que l'émotion
évolue change de camp que l'opinion
publique elle aussi évolue et c'était
prévisible que l'opinion publique allait
changé bien sûr tout à fait d'abord l'E
frroid à l'égard de cette terrible
attaque du 7 octobre qui a tué 1200
israéliens dans leur maison des bébés
des enfants des femmes enceintes des
vieillards et aujourd'hui et bien le
même effroid à l'égard des 10000 Gazaoui
tués dans leur maison des bébés qui
meurent à l'hôpital faute d'électricité
de tous ces Palestiniens que nous nous
représentons aujourd'hui tous dans une
prison à ciel ouvert d'où et bien
l'évolution du discours politique
l'évolution du discours d'Emmanuel
Macron il n'est pas le seul prenez même
le plus grand soutien d'Israël les
États-Unis Joe Biden qui a martelé
qu'Israël avait le devoir de se défendre
et bien regardez ces dernières
déclarations sur X par exemple voilà ce
qu'il dit vous avez ma parole je
continuerai à plaider en faveur de la
sécurité des civils et à me concentrer
sur l'augmentation de l'aide pour
soulager les souffrances de la
population de Gaza donc vous dites que
leur position ont évolué mais Emmanuel
Macron lui toujours été sur une ligne de
crête un peu fragile voilà il a toujours
été dans le en même temps c'est son ADN
à Emmanuel Macron on se rappelle de son
déplacement proche- Orient où il a
affiché son plein soutien à Israël lors
d'une conférence de presse commune avec
Benjamin netaniaahou avant de se rendre
en S Jordanie pour s'entretenir avec le
président de l'Autorité palestinienne
marmudabbas avant la Jordanie l'Égypte
de son déplacement on a surtout retenu
l'idée de la coalition internationale
mais en réalité c'est surtout un moment
où une a cess de plaider pour une
solution à deux états objectif placer la
France dans une position médiale une
position d'équilibre une position de
médiation ce qui est la position qu'il
avait d'ailleurs aussi recherché dans la
guerre en Ukraine en continuant à aller
voir Vladimir Poutine au risque alors de
brouiller l'image de la France
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui je voudrais
repréciser la prise de parole d'Emmanuel
Macron sur la BBC ce n'est pas
réellement un revirement parce que
quelques heures plus tard d'ailleurs il
s'est entretenu avec le président
israélien Isaac Herzog pour lui dire
qu'Israël a entièrement le droit de se
défendre vous savez quoi et ben dans
l'entretien de la BBC si on l'écoute en
longueur et pas juste la phrase qu'on a
isolé il dit pas autre chose donc pour
conclure je voudrais dire attention aux
citations tronquées et attention à notre
écoute aussi qui peut-être sélective
parce que pour en revenir à ce que j'ai
dit au début dès le 12 octobre Emmanuel
Macron disait dans sa première
déclaration solennelle au français
Israël a le droit de se défendre en
éliminant les groupes terroristes dont
le Hamas par des actions ciblées mais en
préservant les population civile car
c'est là le devoir des démocraties il
faut prendre la phrase en entier mais à
l'époque on avait surtout entendu le
soutien à Israël et c'est aussi pour ça
qu'on a l'impression qu'il a changé de
pied il a pas au fer Bronstein il a pas
changé de pied vous dites-vous mais
est-ce qu'on peut prenner à la fois un
cesser le feu et l'é radication du Hamas
en même temps oui moi j'ai suivi la
crise dans un verre d'eau depuis
avant-hier j'ai géré j'ai j'ai j'ai mis
en contact le président les deux
présidents d'ailleurs il a pas parlé
coprésident ces derniers jours il a
parlé à d'autres leaders israéliens qui
le S qui le soutiennent totalement euh
ça c'est à lui de de le dire c'est pas à
moi et c'est qui le soutienne totalement
il n'a pas il n'a pas changé d'un yota
sa position dès le départ comme vous le
dites c'est c'est ce qu'on veut entendre
ou c'est le rôle fourbe des médias
parfois qui qui mettent en avant quelque
chose et l'écoute sélective il a l'oreil
cassé l'écoute sélectif sa position elle
a été claire dès le départ le khamas
c'est une organisation terroriste et il
dit autre chose aux Israéliens alors
comment le mettre en marche ça il
travaille c'est pas le problème des
Israéliens c'est le problème de la
communauté internationale donc on va
créer une une organisation une coalition
internationale pour combattre le Hamas
c'est c'est quelque chose qu'on voulait
tous entendre la deuxième chose qu'il
dit bien entendu il condamne l'attaque
et et vous savez il y a des familles
d'hôge qui se trouvent à Paris presque
chaque semaine euh les présidents du
Sénat les ont rencontré le président
Macron les a rencontré trois fois la
madame Macron l'a rencontré la semaine
dernière donc il y a vraiment un un
soutien euh à à aux Israéliens et et et
et au au mots de de la société
israélienne qu'est-ce qu'il dit aussi in
cessz le feu pas pour permettre au Hamas
de se mais pour essayer d'éviter la
catastrophe humanitaire dans laquelle on
se trouve et on peut faire les deux le
Hamas ne va pas être détruit ni
aujourd'hui ni demain ni après-demain il
va être très affaibli mais si on veut le
détruire il y a d'autres moyens le
président Macron parle pour le détruire
et ce sont des moyens politiques avec
les flux financiers euh notamment et en
particul aussi le Hamas va être détruit
par des livres par par par par par le
bien-être de la population par le le
l'espoir qu'on va donner aux enfants qui
qui naissent aujourd'hui à à Gaza ça ne
va pas être détruit par des armes améour
qu'est-ce qu'on peut imaginer comme
évolution de la situation politique en
sisjordanie côté palestinien vous nous
disiez marmou Abas c'est décrédibilisé
ça profite à qui au Hamas implanté sur
place au Djihad islamique oui bien sûr
ça leur profite puisqueen plus donc
comme je disais il y a une recrudescence
des activités du Hamas en sixjordanie
qui est assez inquiétante depuis depuis
plusieurs mois et encore plus depuis le
7 octobre il y a eu 90 attentats qui ont
été perpétrés par le ramas et d'autres
factions en 6h d' nuit il y a eu
énormément d'arrestations et surtout en
fait on voit que les les Palestiniens de
sisjordanie voit les bombardement sur
Gaza sentent que les Palestiniens de
Gaza sont déshumanisés et voi on ne peut
que s'en désoler mais le Hamas comme un
mouvement de résistance plutôt que comme
un mouvement terroriste c'est ça qui
fait qu'ils vont peut-être vouloir le
soutenir il y a eu énormément de euh
rapport comme quoi les prêches
devenaient pendant les les funérailles
de combattants de plus en plus politique
on sent que il y a un engouement pour ce
qui est vu comme de la résistance et euh
je ne sais vraiment pas où tout cela
peut mener dimono la S Jordanie c'est
une des clés euh pour sortir du conflit
je parla évidemment pas demain ni
après-demain mais dans les années qui
viennent est-ce qu'on peut imaginer un
jour Israël quitter euh la S Jordanie
les colons sortirent de s Jordanie on
rappelle déjà que ça vaa été très
compliqué euh pour que 8000 colons
sortent de Gaza en 2005 là on parle de
on a vu tout à l'heure 460000 personnes
non
al moi je serais pas enfin moi ce que ce
qui me questionne beaucoup c'est ok on
parle de cette position en même temps
d'Emmanuel Macron enfin du moins la
prétention qu'il veut montrer de ce en
même temps mais quel levier on a en tant
que politique étrangère quel instrument
de pression avons-nous énorme sur le
gouvernement israélien oui lequel si si
on veut oui voilà on veut l'exercer
voilà si on veut l'exercer c'est ça ma
ma remarque alors dites-le lequel par
exemple des accords en terme
d'association avec Israël on a compèd
dans certain nombre de domaines par
exemple on peut très bien mettre ça
là-dessus il y a eu l'Union européenne à
travaillé sur la labellisation des
produits qui sont
euh produit agricoles notamment euh dans
la en sjordanie notamment dans la vallée
du Jourdin voilà donc la question c'est
aussi qu'est-ce qu'on veut peser en fait
véritablement là-dessus parce que pour
l'instant on a quand même une diplomatie
qui est plutôt de de l'ordre du
discursif qui par exemple condamne
lorsque les Israéliens détruisent des
écoles financées par des fonds européens
et c'est tout en fait si on replacee
cela dans une temparalité qui n'est pas
une guerre chaude comme on a maintenant
mais qu'on le prend sur le temps long
quel quels sont les les les leviers que
nous avons mis en œuvre sur ce
dossiererbonstein on peut imaginer un
jour Israël retirer les colons de s
Jordanie oui oui parce que c'est pas
retirer les colons c'est retiré
uniquement 15 % des colons euh les pour
parler très avant
eu entre le Premier ministre ou qui a dû
démissionner pour des raisons
personnelles un scandale et le président
Abbas était très très
poussé après y avait l'initiative de
Genève il y a d'autres initiatives dans
le même sens ça parlait étonné que la
plupart des colonies se trouvent dans
dans la zone C ok la zone C c'est aussi
la plus grande au niveau territorial
donc qui celle qui est
administrée par Israël si on laisse 80 %
des colonies en zone C sur à peu près
10% 12 % du territoire et que Israël sur
ces 12 % permettra soit à Gaza de se
développer un peu et Gaza en a besoin
pour respirer soit dans le nord de la
sjordanie versgie de de de se développer
un peu on peut on peut résoudre le
problème en démontrant que très peu de
de de de colonies et on permettant aux
Palestiniens de recevoir la même
quantité de territoire qui a été qui a
été occupé en 1967 c'est c'est de la
volonté politique qu'il manque c'est de
la détermination politique qu'il manque
c'est du cour de la part de la
communauté internationale mais aussi de
la part des Israéliens et palestinen
bien sûr tout d'abord c'est pour ça que
moi je pense qu'il faut changer les
paradigmes il faut pas on a dit aux
Israéliens au Palestiniens jusqu'à
maintenant négocier négocier on voit ça
ça a pas marché toutes les négociations
pour des raisons de politique interne
pour des raisons de de géopolitique
n'ont pas fonctionné je crois qu'il faut
vous savez la France par exemple mais
pas seulement dit nous on est pour la
solution des deux états tout le monde
les Américains solution des deux états
même laatania dit solution desat
faisons-le moi encore une fois je je je
suis libre je je suis pas persuadé que
je représente les opinions du du
président Macron mais moi je à la place
de la France je reconnais l'État
palestinien maintenant et je dis après
aux israïliens Palestiniens après régler
les problèmes des frontières les
problèmes de la capitale les problèmes
des réfugiés mais un État palestinien
devient une réalité ça change au niveau
politique au niveau de l'atmosphère au
niveau du sentiment des Palestiniens ça
change totalement les paradigmes
améisacour vous étiez en poste
jusqu'encore très récemment au Liban la
solution à deux états c'est encore
quelque chose qui est qui est qui est
envisagé ou imaginé dans la région
euh
ouis non pas vraiment parce que le le
territoire palestinien est vra enfin la
sisjordanie est vraiment morcelé en fait
de colonies donc techniquement on ne
sait pas comment ça peut arriver donc il
y a d'autres il y a d'autres
propositions qui émergent comme un état
avec des droits égau pour tout le monde
ça marchera pas c'est une guerre civile
vous connaissez bien au Liban é à moitié
israélien à moitié palestinien alors
qu'il se haissent alors qu'il y a pas
d'empathie de l'un vers l'autre ça va
être la catastrophe on n'est pas prêt
moi moi mon modèle à moi c'est l'Europe
moi je suis inspiré par l'Europe
détruite après la guerre complètement
détruite après la deuxième guerre
mondiale et qui qui agi on est on est un
espace de de paix mais mais ça va
prendra il faut rééduquer une génération
il faut retirer le poison que les uns
les autres ont on n'est pas prêt pour
l'instant un seul État Damen Damien SIM
la solution un état une nation
arc-en-ciel en fait la question c'est de
replacer le le le processus de
négociation non pas nécessairement sur
le territoire mais sur les droits les
droits politiques l'égalité des droits
entre un israélien et un palestinen
alors vous nous avez rappelé tout à
l'heure que ils n'ont pas les mêmes
droits voilà bien sûr mais on est au
cœur une discrimination c'est évident
mais du coup il y a en effet dans les
sociétés civiles des réflexions
là-dessus c'est sûr que ce n'est pas le
paradigme dominant de notre côté là et
on peut en effet parler de la la
faisabilité bien évidemment mais c'est
déplacer la question non pas de
l'attachement au territoire mais de
l'attachement au droits des individus
dans cet espace entre la Méditerranée et
le Jourdain le droit dans leur étatà
c'est sur ce changement de prisme
arrêtons de penser au territoire pensons
au droit que nous allons conclure
momentanément ce débat et en tout cas
conclure pour ce soir cette émission
merci à tous les TR C d' avoir participé
merci Tam de m'avoir accompagné c'est
donc la fin de ce débat demain matin
c'est la députée insoumise de scè
saint-den Raquel garido qui sera
l'invité de la matinale d'orian mansini
et dès demain soir vous retrouverez bien
sûr Thomas HUG pour un nouveau numéro de
sens publ merci à
tous